so Bernie's first mayor Pete second
globish our third poor Liz came in
fourth but it was a photo finish all
evidence is that Elizabeth Warren has
finished out of the money she has
finished fourth she is still at work
Elizabeth Warren who lives just to the
south in the state of New Hampshire is
taking a picture with all who asks this
isn't lonely to me this is awesome I
love this she's a really really good
candidate great she's on her way to
becoming a Walmart Santa and MSNBC so
supportive they sounded like your buddy
after you get dumped saying don't worry
there's other fish in the sea in handy a
can of tuna but she doesn't just take
pictures no she'll take your last three
bucks young woman came up by herself and
she said I'm a broke college student
with a lot of student loan debt and she
said I checked and I have six dollars in
the bank so I just gave three dollars to
keep you in this fight that's what we
gotta do that's what we got to do take
half your money typical Democrat without
a thought Joe came in fifth
so like the time I stained a table with
a cheap varnish it was a disappointing
finish yeah that joke is every bit as
bad as Joe's campaign so what we learn
authenticity rules even when you're
authentically wrong about everything
remember every day Bernie chooses
socialism over capitalism and polling
shows Americans will never vote for a
socialist so Bernie may do more to
reelect Trump than Trump speaking of
Trump take a look at these numbers
calling that a win is like calling the
coronavirus the sniffles right Chris
they just want to be secure in their own
economy in their own lives and see their
kids once in a while if that's the case
Trump is gonna be tough to beat so I
don't know I think in either case I
think it's gonna be tough to beat Trump
I'm a bit first frustrated and I'm
they answer to all questions Brian Brian
him right sir I'm just not tonight I'm a
little frustrated somebody get him a
therapy chicken as for Joe he said you
can't win a general election as a
Democrat unless you have overwhelming
support from black and brown voters so
what does this mean well it's a knock
against mayor Pete who the media says
has a black voter problem I suppose if
they were white conservative voters the
media would just say they're homophobes
meanwhile Trump may get the most black
votes for a Republican in a really long
time because he's done good for blacks
creating an economy that favors all
citizens so let's ponder this contrast
the Dems say to Black's you're a victim
of the past and we're gonna get you
damages but then they don't Trump says
to Black's you're gonna do great right
now and I'm gonna help you and he does
which one sounds best to you to be
Victor or victim the Dems know the
answer no wonder chris is miserable so
welcome back Dana in one we missed you
we're only three people at this table
tables very lonely without you - well
you like what's in one I saw an
interesting picture of you this morning
with the person who I believe is the
real winner there you are in the morning
with Amy Clopas char is there something
we should know you know love is in the
air it's Valentine's Day you know I like
to jump on a bandwagon and she's rolling
yes what do you think what do you think
of the results well I mean for someone
like senator Klobuchar I think you
really have to look at the next two
states does she have an end does he have
the infrastructure the organization on
the ground and I don't think she does
the reason I saw at the at Logan Airport
this morning in Boston where she was on
her way to New York to raise money no
and so she's got to get some you know
money in the pocket in order to do that
to me you know a lot of the stuff in the
monologue I was thinking about one yes
there's a lot of infighting among the
Democrats right now but again I think
that dynamic shifts once you get a
Democratic nominee and you know we had
some polling that showed you know most
people now think Trump will win and
again I think yeah people said that
about Hillary Clinton back in 2016 they
everybody
oh yeah Hillary's gonna win this don't
worry about it to me you can't
extrapolate from an intra-party fight or
a tough set of primaries where you have
you know what I call the roller coaster
where Joe Biden looks like he's gone off
the rail we don't know I mean we don't
know what's to come I will say he
doesn't look good if I you know my dad
used to train boxers and he would say
son you better get your ass in gear that
guy's whipping your ass right now yeah
so I think that that's what's going on
with Joe Biden but he does
unlike Klobuchar have infrastructure on
the ground in South Carolina and even
leading establishment Democrat officials
in Nevada on his I'm thinking Harry Reid
the former US Senate Majority Leader
Jesse do you have is there hope for Joe
no I don't think so I mean he's hanging
on by his fingertips and I don't think
he has what it takes to pull it back
together
I hate watched MSNBC last night you did
not I did but after a few minutes I
really started liking it because they
can't stand any of their own Candle
right yeah I mean you see the part where
they watch the livestream of Joe Biden's
from the from South Carolina and they
just absolutely trashed it yes I saw
that part too they were like that dude
they were like it's so bad that was the
best part of the night they were making
fun of the front-runner and they just
couldn't hold back I mean mayor Pete had
a good night but you have to ask
yourself is America ready for the first
gay president I mean I am because I'm
very open-minded
oh but we're told I just don't know if
the rest of the country is not to
mention millions of Democrats Bernie
Sanders is a radical socialist to
honeymooned in Moscow he can't lead the
country can't even unite his own party
so he's toast Biden as I said he's
running on fumes Warren's pretty much
toast and then you have Klobuchar who
gave a great speech last night but she
doesn't have the cash to go the distance
and do you actually think a OSI and the
Bernie bros are gonna let mini Mike
Bloomberg swoop in with all that cash
and wrench away the nomination no the
Democrats are completely panicking right
now
Nancy's ratings are down CNN's ratings
are down at this point it looks like the
media and the Democrats are creating
Trump supporters look at that turnout
last night in New Hampshire broke
records speaking of which another
stock market record today Gallup shows
Americans are rich happy and content
with their pocketbook situation now the
Democrats have to ask themselves who are
we going to lose with because they're
not going to win is it Bernie or bust
and that's why everyone's playing nice
because they know they're gonna have to
broker it in Milwaukee so no one wants
to say anything mean because they might
wind up on the ticket Dana that is some
pretty perceptive stuff from just very
very good feedback I missed everybody
very much we did too I've sat your chair
I love saying no I think else I just
felt more analytic I feel like so what
sounded like a dog I think that Fox News
did an incredible job over the past like
two weeks like all the coverage and I
think the recovering this Democratic
primary very well very fairly very
interestingly because we're willing to
say some things and one of those is that
you have to realize that in New
Hampshire a lot of the people that said
their first choice was Biden their
second choice was not Amy Klobuchar or
mayor Pete it was Bernie Sanders so that
makes me think that one might have a
point that okay well if it is Bernie
there's a lot of people willing to get
on that bandwagon but if Mike Bloomberg
tries to come in and if they tried I do
not see the Bernie people ever
coalescing behind a Michael Bloomberg
candidacy I've never actually seen
anybody get on a bandwagon I've never
seen a bandwagon well we should do bad I
guess yeah
Katie for the Nevada caucuses we should
ban and wagon around Nevada Oh would
that be fun yeah that would be fun yes
yes Fox reporters have been amazing
being at the different rallies and the
different candidate I mean they were
election they were great think I'm so
great is introducing out Peter Doocy
understand everybody is doing an amazing
job it's interesting to see Amy
Klobuchar rise and you know the question
is will this give anybody a momentum
going into South Carolina South Carolina
voters aren't necessarily going to
change their vote based on Iowa or New
Hampshire but donors and people who deal
with infrastructure are paying attention
that's what Amy Koch cars in New York
raising money
I'm sure mayor Pete is still getting a
lot of phone calls asking how people can
get maybe some Biden donors are making
those phone calls trying to figure out
how they can help them where do you need
the most money
want to do bad buys you wanted it do
this how are we gonna play the the
delegate field here but Bernie Sanders
is on a roll
and I think long term and for the rest
of the year in the country people really
need to start thinking about where we
are in this in this moment because as
AOC said it added Bernie rally last week
decades of activism in the college
campuses you know going back are paying
off to this moment and it's absolutely
true and it's not going away because the
majority of Bernie's fans are young
people and I doubt that they're just
gonna change the ideology so as a
country it's important to point out
where we are and it's the to set
different sets of how we run things and
go about it's not like there are little
differences here these are completely
different systems and I would say Bernie
Sanders wasn't honeymooning in the USSR
when it was socialist he was there when
it was a communist country it's still
communist today and he's praised
communists in the past so I think
calling the Socialists actually giving
him an easy way out in his policies
alrighty
that's true